the future involves the word no
we need to be able to use the word no
only by saying no
will you be able to say yes only by
saying no
to certain destructive ideologies will
you be able to say yes
to edifying to building up again only by
saying no
to critical race theory to radical
gender ideology
to this nihilistic secularism that is
pervading the culture only by saying
no we will not tolerate that in our
schools in our institutions in our
workplaces
by saying no we will be able to say
there is such a thing as truth
we can know things not just physical
scientific things but moral things
philosophical things even religious
things
we can know that in our politics and we
can build up
from there we need to
stop being so damn nice you mentioned at
the top
um that you learned some stuff as you
were going through the book and coming
up with some of these
ideas what was something else that you
really learned while writing because
that's the
to me that was the fun part of writing
when i was like oh i really have to dive
in
and not just say these things and
understand them at a service level you
really got to get in there and and
pull out the important stuff i i learned
that a lot of what we have come to
regard
as just com and i'm talking on the right
i'm talking among conservatives a lot of
what we've come to regard
as the the nature of our american regime
and the
kind of nature of the founding and how
we understand ourselves in free speech
is kind of bunk and it was kind of just
they're just bumper stickers from the
last 20 years or so and and i
i came to a grudging respect even for
the most
vile of the leftist theorists i'll give
a good example
is herbert marcuza herbert marcuza he
was he was actually mocked in that um
coen brothers movie hail caesar
he's sort of the villain of that movie
so so herbert marcusa
was one of the critical theorists one of
the og's in the frogfort school
and he developed a lot of these
ideologies in
in the marxist tradition in the western
marxist tradition
thinking specifically about culture and
then he pops up again
he goes and he works for the precursor
to the cia for a while he goes into the
academy for a while
then he pops up again in the 60s as the
father of the new left i mean he's
considered
maybe the most influential figure during
the radical movements of the 60s
and marcus writes one of the most
infamous essays on free speech
ever composed it was called repressive
tolerance
repres seems like a contradiction in
terms and marcus says
he's got a lot of like silly jargon that
you can kind of ignore then he comes to
the heart of it he says
a liberating tolerance would not
tolerate intolerance which he defines as
conservative thought and he and he
observes that the conservatives had
cultural hegemony they had sort of
control over the institutions
they control over the common sense and
so what we need to do to correct that
is censor and suppress the conservatives
and advance the radical leftist thought
and he was decried by people certainly
people on the right and and people on
the left as well
but his his basic point that you can't
tolerate intolerance
is correct that's actually true it's the
same tolerance
yes yeah it is and conservatives need to
learn this
lesson that i i think that the
conservative vision
i think the american vision of free
speech and the way we all live together
is a very tolerant one i think it's the
most tolerant one
basically ever in history but
that is now being undone and it's being
explicitly undone by the radicals the
1619 project
the critical race theorists and the
whole kitten caboodle and by the way
people in elected office i mean even all
the way up to the biden administration
and so that is being undone because we
fail to recognize that marcus was right
there were some things that are
non-negotiable going back to bill
buckley
bill buckley's second book was a defense
of joe mccarthy mccarthyism the
anti-communist crusader
shocking right years later i mean
buckley came to temper his
his defense of mccarthy mostly on
practical grounds that mccarthy kind of
screwed things up
but i think it was about a dozen years
after that book came out
buckley was talking to a neoconservative
uh leo chern
and they were debating on his tv show
and sharon said you're for an open
society bill aren't you don't you we
want a big
open society coincidentally the type
that's the name of george soros's
philanthropic foundation
so you can see how this has a leftward
lurch and and bill said
no i don't no i don't think society
should be totally open
i want the society to be considerably
more closed and he used a ridiculous
phrase he said
i'm an epistemological optimist and he
kind of made fun of himself he said what
that means is
i think that some things are settled i
think that some things we don't actually
need to rehash i don't think
that we need to rehash nazism i don't
think we need to rehash communism
and he the point he's making is not just
one of practical politics
he's actually making a point about
knowledge how we know
things certain things you just have to
assume
in mathematics you have to just assume
certain axioms
a equals a a plus b equals b plus a
right certain things that i can't prove
i can't but you have to just assume it i
have to assume
that my faculties of reason are somewhat
reliable
i have to assume it i have to assume
that objective truth exists
i have to assume it because otherwise i
am rendered
speechless what i mean by that is i
can't you can't make an argument
if there is no such thing as objective
truth and if we don't have faculties of
reason so you have to assume those
things
and when people come in and try to
obliterate your belief in those things
you must resist it and you must suppress
that it's so interesting to me because
you're basically making the argument for
why
i can't call myself a liberal with a
straight face anymore
because of the objective truth issue
that you're bringing up and the paradox
of tolerance which is why the
seven remaining liberals that are
flailing around right now
you you you talk about the squishy
republicans or the squishy conservatives
i see them as the the ineffectual
liberals it's like
you you guys let this in you have now
none of the tools to deal with it but
your biggest
fear i mean i say this all the time but
your biggest fear is that you don't want
to be called
conservative and it's like yeah they're
not coming for you
and you you've done this thing which is
not permitted anymore in society
which is you've thought about things and
changed your mind on some issues right
and unfortunately forget about the left
they're not changing their mind either
they're quite successful so why would
they but the right refuses to change its
mind i think
the right had some good ideas and then
they turn those ideas into slogans and
they turn those slogans into bumper
stickers
and every bumper sticker is wrong you
can reality will not be
distilled into a few pithy little
sayings on a napkin
and they they refuse to rethink it so
the right knows
at this point that it's in a losing
strategy right the right knows that it's
just losing ground after ground does it
even when we
win elections we lose but they're not
willing to rethink things
look at objective reality with new eyes
and
change their mind so so i i see you
flailing your arms or you know you're
probably shaking people by the shoulders
for the for the seven remaining liberals
but one could do the same thing about
the conservatives who who fail to
recognize
that the strategy that they may have
adopted in the best hopes
has not worked because reality was a
little different than that theory and
we've got to rethink
our history we've got to rethink our
philosophy and we've got to
actually try to win again so on that
note nols
let's let's end with this because i've
got a heart out today even though i
could do 20 hours with you obviously
uh what does the future that you're
writing about in that book that i wrote
about in my book that we talk about all
the time
what does it actually look like what
what can we be doing what can we be
messaging
to the people that watch our shows that
get it they don't want to be the broken
liberals
they don't want to be the dis the
squishy republicans
conservatives what what is it that we're
building and and who's going to help us
build it
because that's the whole thing that i'm
always going for now
the future involves the word no
we need to be able to use the word no
only by saying no
will you be able to say yes only by
saying no
to certain destructive ideologies will
you be able to say yes
to edifying to building up again only by
saying
no to critical race theory to radical
gender ideology
to this nihilistic secularism that is
pervading the culture only by saying no
we will not tolerate that in our schools
in our institutions in our workplaces
by saying no we will be able to say
there is such a thing as truth
we can know things not just physical
scientific things but moral things
philosophical things even religious
things we can know that in our politics
and we can build up from there we need
to uh stop being so damn nice
and we also need to get rid of the
premises that that our adversaries have
foisted on us you know
when when the squishes for the last 20
or 30 years have only focused on
economic issues right you hear this a
lot i'm a i'm a fiscal conservative but
social liberal or whatever
they i don't even know what that means
anymore it doesn't mean anything anymore
it doesn't mean
it means you're a conservative who
doesn't want to admit it or because
you're really a guilty liberal or
something like that yeah
yes and it also if you say that all i
care
about is economics you're saying the
same thing as the socialist
the socialist views man as essentially
an economic being
yes it's just it's just like stuff you
know and and the
the squishy conservative is saying the
same thing we need to say something
different
phyllis schlafly one of the great
conservative leaders of the last century
had a very famous saying she said we
need a choice not an
echo and what we've had so far is a left
that is putting forward a vision of
society
and we've had a right that basically
agrees with them
or is unwilling to have the courage to
stand up to them but one does need
courage we need to accept the reality
that there is truth and there is virtue
and we need to recognize that the
prerequisite virtue
is courage it's not enough to lose with
dignity as all the undignified people do
you have to have the courage to make
claims to enforce those claims
and to win if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell